what was Art the clown going to do with
one unlucky character's body part in a
different version of the film well it
wouldn't have been pretty warning
spoilers ahead
terrifier 2 is one of the most extreme
horror movies in recent memory Damian
Leone's slasher has made over 11 million
dollars as of November 2022 proving
moviegoers can stomach some gruesome
scarefair that said if the filmmakers
included every scene they wanted to
terrifier 2 would probably have been
banned from most theaters the bloody
slasher which is a sequel to 2016's
terrifier centers around art a mass
murdering clown who enjoys disposing of
his victims in the nastiest ways
imaginable however while the movie is
disturbing us atrocities are so
memorable that he'll undoubtedly go down
in history as one of his generation's
horror icons so what is it about
terrifier 2 that's made it one of 2022's
most controversial films well one scene
sees the clown gunning down and burning
people in a clown Cafe in another scene
art breaks into a woman's house scalpser
rips off her arms and leaves her hanging
around like a display soaking in her own
blood even the quieter moments and
terrifier two are disturbing like the
sequence in which art silently taunts
the patrons of a costume shop sir what
would aim that terrifier 2 pushes the
envelope but it almost went too far
during a recent interview the only
revealed that there was one scene that
he had to scrap from the movie because
he knew that it would have been too much
for viewers to stomach one scene shows
art stabbing one unfortunate guy's
manhood before removing it completely
it's one of the most grown-inducing
moments in the movie but it could have
been so much worse while speaking to
variety Leone revealed that they were
tempted to have us continue mocking his
castrated victim after removing his junk
in the end the director opted against it
as he felt that some of the ideas he had
in mind were too distasteful to paint a
picture the filmmakers considered
turning the severed genitalia into well
a balloon animal but eventually came to
their senses of course a fact this
suggestion was even considered sums up
the attitude on the set of terrifier 2.
they only told the magazine we're always
trying to one-up each other and come up
with sick things but that one was too
far for me he probably made the right
decision in the end considering the
scenes included in the film caused
enough upset to Mongolian's members
already it's long been said that
controversy creates cash and this
age-old adage Rings true for terrifier
too in fact most horror filmmakers and
Studios would kill for the attention the
movie received most of which was organic
and based on Word of Mouth the film also
garnered headlines for making viewers
sick pass out and go to the hospital
according to USA Today and then before
you know it it's friggin uh blowing up
just blowing up in horror circles though
this reaction to terrifier 2 only added
to its Allure and Intrigue but Leoni was
just as shocked by the news stories
surrounding the film as everyone else he
told Entertainment Weekly listen I would
have loved to have a couple of walkouts
I think that's sort of a badge of honor
because it's an intense movie I don't
want people fainting or getting hurt
during the movie be but it's surreal